[Music]
Joshua you asked a really great question
why is there no gravity in space I bet
you've seen pictures of the astronauts
up in the space station and they're
floating around as if there's no gravy
at all and this is actually a really
interesting misconception about what's
going on with the astronauts and it gets
to one of my favorite questions all of
astronomy and that is what is an orbit
what's happening when astronauts are
orbiting the Earth and why does it
appear like there's no gravity in space
so to talk about why this is kind of a
misconception the astronauts are about
200 miles above the surface of the earth
in the space station Space Station
orbits around us about once every 90
minutes and it's not that they're so far
away from the earth that there's no
gravity in fact if you built a
skyscraper that was 200 miles tall and
you were up on one of those top floors
you might weight a tiny little bit less
but you'd probably weigh at least about
80% what you normally would
you're really not that much farther away
from the earth so it's not that they're
weightless because they're in space and
far away from the earth they're actually
close enough to the earth to feel the
gravitational pull of the earth itself
so what's going on why are they floating
around well this is what an orbit really
is we have to get spacecraft going very
very fast to put them into orbit that's
why we put them on Rockets Rockets
launch spacecraft and get them going
very very fast and if you're in orbit
where the space station is you're
traveling at about 17,000 miles an hour
now what happens to those astronauts is
that they're going very very fast but
they're actually freely falling towards
the Earth the earth has gravity and that
gravity is pulling them down just the
same as what would happen is if you
dropped a ball if you dropped a ball it
would fall to the floor the same thing
is happening to the astronauts they are
falling towards the surface of the earth
but here's the cool thing they're going
so fast they keep missing the earth as
they fall and that's the definition of
an orbit now think about it this way I
talked about dropping a ball the ball
just falls straight down what would
happen if I put the ball in a little
cannon and shot it out the ball would
start to drop
the earth the minute it left the cannon
but the cannon has given it some
velocity and so the ball might go a
hundred yards right it might actually go
a hundred yards before it fell because
the cannon gave it that velocity now
let's take it even bigger cannon let's
take a huge cannon that can shoot things
many many miles so you shoot the ball
out the ball is still falling freely
towards the Earth
all the time but now it goes farther
because you've given it more velocity
and maybe with a really big hand and you
could shoot a ball 100 miles what about
with a rocket with a rocket you could
get something going so fast up to 17,000
miles an hour that as it fell freely
towards Earth Earth would keep curving
away under it and it would keep missing
it that's what an orbit is and that's
why you need a rocket to get into orbit
you need to get yourself going so fast
that as you fall back towards Earth you
keep missing it so the astronauts are
not weightless because there's no
gravity in space the astronauts are
falling the same way a skydiver is
falling freely through space it's just
that they're going so fast they keep
missing the earth there all the time
falling towards the earth going fast
enough that they keep missing it
everything that's in orbit around
anything else is doing the same thing
right now you and I are falling freely
towards the Sun but the earth is moving
actually at about 30,000 miles an hour
and we keep missing the Sun as we go
around it and that means we're in orbit
around the Sun the moon is in orbit
around the Earth it's falling towards
the earth is just traveling so fast it
keeps missing it
you've asked an excellent question
everything in space that is orbiting is
freely falling under gravity it's just
going too fast to ever hit anything
you